Both sides doing.
But what we have seen over the past for years is a group of individuals from the
FBI, from the CIA who are leaking pieces of information to kneecap,
a duly elected president,
so that they can put the people in power that they choose irrespective of party,
whether it's a never Trumper or whether it's one of these, you know,
more traditional, moderate Democrat, what the hell that means these days.
Piece of this,
which you've sort of been hitting on here is the media portion and how all of
these leaks,
every day you open up the New York times or CNN or MSNBC,
and they're reporting on stuff that's supposed to be behind closed doors.
There are secret congressional meetings about things,
but somehow MSNBC in the New York times has all of ships talking points and the
rest of it, how does this game actually get played? Like,
is it as obviously ridiculous as,
and just so blatant as it seems, could it be that blatant?
Yeah, it, it is look, um, most of the leaking so that the,
when you work in Washington,
you find out very quickly that most of the leaking occurs either by the white
house, interestingly enough,
or by the senior levels of the various departments and agencies, it's,
it's rarely that lower or working level individual, right?
It's the people who, again, like Aldrich,
Ames have decided that they know what's best for the country.
So they're going to act on it. They're going to leak things to try to push, uh,
the media narrative and at one direction or another based on whatever they want,
whether their goals are their personal goals. We saw that with comi. I mean,
we know he leaked the New York times via cut-out to try to push for an
independent counsel and he got it.
So it's not as though this tactic doesn't work, it does work.
So that's probably that's your friend. Yes. Yeah. So, uh, both sides doing,
but what we have seen over the past for years is a group of individuals from the
FBI, from the CIA who are leaking pieces of information to kneecap,
a duly elected president so that they can put the people in power that they
choose irrespective of party,
whether it's a never Trumper or whether it's one of these, you know,
more traditional, moderate Democrat, where the hell that means these days.
Right. Well, it's not right.
Really irrespective of party. Right? Cause it's,
you mean a never Trumper or some other Democrat.
But I mean, historically the leaks have,
have come from both sides of the aisle to,
to the media because of their own personal desire to shape policy. Right.
We're just seeing it on steroids. Now, the amount of leaking th the,
the ferociousness of the impact of those leaks, right. That it's not just,
we like this, or we don't like this. It's, you know, Trump is a, is a trader,
or it's going to launch this in world war three, or it's that absurdities,
that history that, that was kicked off in 2016.
Do you think that's partly just because we're just watching institutions crumble
across the board. And so they're all sort of in their death throws,
so you just throw out everything. So, you know what I mean?
Like we're watching our media institutions crumble,
our political institutions are crumbling.
We're exposing information conversations like this weren't really being had five
years ago. So as it all becomes more obvious, the ways it can lash out,
become crazier.
So as, as the curtain is pulled back on the wizard of Oz,
he not get a little bit more panicked.
About people understanding he was like four foot, two, 250 pounds. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that, that could explain a lot, because again, at some level,
when you start looking at, for instance, let's just take the media, right?
So it's long been known that the media focuses on one particular party and
benefiting them. And it's a democratic party, which by the way,
when you get like 95% of your political funds or that,
that is the media support you like from their political donations,
it's incredible that the Republican party even exists. Right.
We have that degree of an avalanche of support in your nation's media.
The fact that another party exists is really incredible.
Or it means a Denver reminder. I'm looking at a lifelong Democrat.
I want to say that again. So look in.
The last 10 to 15 years, forget that five.
Years we'll get to that. We're going to get over it. But yeah.
You're right to say that the media is recognizing that we're all pulling off the
mask and seen who they are,
and that is horrifying to them because the moment that we start questioning
their authority to tell us what's right and wrong. And we start saying,
you know what,
actually you've given to the other political party used to work for that another
organization or entity that is now against Trump, or like,
we now know that your bias and that's fine. Right?
You and I both have an opinion.
We've heard we both go on TV and talk about things in our opinions. That's fine,
but let's be candid about who we are and what we believe in.
And it's not pass it as news because it's not news. It's just an opinion, right?
It's interesting of the former editor of New York times, uh,
give this fantastic interview, but she talked about her students, you know,
she left the New York times now,
I believe it's at Yale or one of these fancy IVs.
And she works with students who want to become journalists. And she said,
one of the frustrations that she has is that they all want to report on their
own opinions of what's happening in the world. Right. And not the news.
And it's like, well, amen.
We have been walking down this road for 15 plus years where everybody.
In the [inaudible]. Yeah. So.
So let's have an honest conversation that the Walter Cronkite's are gone and
it's, and it's now, you know, a circus and it's, we,
everybody's got a different performer that they prefer and that's bad,
and we should acknowledge that that's bad. And we should, I think,
as a country and at some point, you know,
when does journalism ring its own bell and say, w we've gone too far.
Let's see if we can do something different.
You read the paper that was formerly the New York times.
Are there phrases that you can see are obvious tells when it's complete nonsense
beyond just unnamed source or source picking it up,
saying putting it back down? Yeah. Yeah. And by the way, as I always say,
every time I knocked the New York times, I would prefer this not be the case.
Amen. Everyone, everyone does it.
The people that I find that are railing against it the most are the people that
don't want this to be the most. You know what I mean? Like just,
don't be totally horrible. I come from.
The middle of nowhere and East rural Oregon,
the way that I was able to get into the CIA was that I went to the Washington
post, New York times. I read it every single day,
back in the late nineties and early two thousands. I took notes on each stories.
I built my knowledge and understanding of the world based on their reporting.
So there was a time when I was a big fan and I appreciated what they were doing
for, for me, for the, for the world, for the country spreading, you know,
what was actually happening. And we've lost that great lady.
And the Washington post has gone even more bananas and bars.
And it's horrible for the Republic because democracies need that voice
to challenge people in power. Uh.
So do you think we're more than anything else,
but I can put a little bit political stuff aside putting,
putting deep state aside,
putting the parties aside that we're really more in an information war at this
point than anything else. It's not even information,
it's really the delivery system of the information or anything else.
You're talking to a guy who put out two tweets expressed a simple political
opinion, no inflammatory language.
Can you just remind me what the tweets were exactly because it's kind of,
you're a former CA ops guy. I think you've proven here these,
this half hour or whatever it is that, you know, what you're talking about.
And here are the two tweets that you've put up.
So both of them basically had to do with, uh,
president Trump or Democrats being crazy.
And one was taking a headline from the Washington post,
which was silly Parson flim-flam did, but I'm not what the hell the,
the headline was.
I was just commenting on the fact that it was silly and that was enough to get
me banned for whatever number of days. Right. Um,
the other was a thread talking, uh, about, uh, the president, uh, and you know,
what we are are this whole impeachment silliness and how absurd it isn't it,
it was a relatively short thread and it was bad. Um, again,
simply taking a snippet from the IgE report and commenting on that
sexual report. That was enough. So that to me, and I know that you,
you have been banging this drum for a long time is incredibly frightening that
we now have a handful of,
of entities from Silicon Valley that are really publishers deciding who gets to
say whatever they want them to say.
And if it goes too far,
either as a corporate policy or as a one off or whatever number
of employees decide, that's bad, they're gonna throw a little sand in the gears,
right. They may not ban you completely, they may,
but they may just throw some sand in the gears and have you blocked for a week
or two or whatever. When, when you want to share something,
a very important time of nation's politics right there during this Iran issue,
right? So we're to throw some sand in your gears,
we're going to stop you from tweeting or stop you from sharing something on
Facebook. That's what they're doing now. That's what they've done.
Does it feel like the whole game is designed to just make us crazier
right now? Like every time, like once you start seeing this stuff, right?
You have your little red, the moment you start seeing this stuff,
you don't want to see it, right. You want to put, uh,
the ocean back in the cup and it just doesn't fit.
Well, I think that this has been a long time coming. So what's interesting is,
uh, uh, MIT did this brilliant study, um, that, uh, in the late nineties,
when some of our economic trade policies were changing China into the WTO, uh,
we had Mexico and Canada NAFTA,
and a lot of the communities that were being negatively, uh,
by these economic changes were starting to elect people to,
to Congress and Senate, uh,
who were increasingly more inflammatory,
increasingly further on the left and further on the right and,
and what you now see that, that created a marketplace for people immediate to,
to be even more loud and bombastic and crazy because people were angry.
And so they were able to tap into that marketplace. Right? So I think that,
that the things that you're seeing in America's media right now are really
reflective of a country that's deeply unsettled.
It doesn't mean that we don't celebrate the progress here in this country,
because economically I think you could make an argument.
And you've had people in this program that made it very clear that we are
benefiting profoundly from our wonderful economic system and perfect as it is
our wonderful Republic and perfect as it is.
But there's clearly a sickness that is being reflected in our media.
That is really at the end of the day, it reflects our own brokenness,
our own anger, because we're, so we're responding in such a visceral way.
We're giving those people. Right.
All right. So let's go to our, what was be beat up lefty guys here for a second,
because as you're saying that I'm reminded of when I used to be on the young
Turks and I was a big lefty that I'd be on air with the host and they'd be
screaming like crazy people about something there's no,
there's no video of me ever screaming about anything like this,
but they'd be screaming this thing,
and then we'd cut to break and then they'd be completely fine. Again,
like completely fine. Then we come back and people are screaming, crying,
or yelling. We're pounding their fists. And I remember thinking like,
this is just all theater.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, check out our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.